new harvard data
accidentally reveals how lockdowns crush
the working class while leaving elites
unscathed right this is a
foundation for economic education data
analysis from harvard university brown
university and the bill and melinda
gates foundation calculates
how different employment levels have
been impacted during the pandemic today
defining
the findings reveals that the government
lockdown orders devastated workers at
the bottom
of the financial food chain but left the
upper tier actually better off it's
interesting that the lockdown was to
protect
the bottom but it actually ended up
hurting the bottom is what it did
the analysis examined employment levels
in january 2020 before the coronavirus
spread wildly before lockdowns orders
and
other restrictions on the economy were
implemented it compared it compared them
to unemployment employment figures
from march 31st 2021 here's the data
employment for
lower wage workers defined as earning
less than 27 000
a year annually declined by a whopping
23.6 percent
over the time period employment for
middle class wage workers defined as
earning between 27 to 60 grand
declined by four and a half percent
however employment for high wage workers
defined as earning more than 60k this is
not even millionaire by the way
above 60k actually increased 2.4 percent
over the measured time period despite
the country's economic turmoil
the datas are damning they offer yet
another reminder that government
lockdowns hurt most
those who could of at least afford it
when you talk about gyms
i can't even tell you how many people
were calling saying where the hell do i
go to work out
our office had a gym people who had no
gym had gym memberships other places
that were shut down they were coming to
the office to work out on the weekends
at our office in in dallas i mean hell i
didn't have a gym
you know getting ready for the olympia
luckily i was able to sneak in with a
key
and literally had to train with the
lights off and parking down the street
so then no one could see me
you know training during the day or at
night my question would be how can i
look like you without needing a gym i
think that's a good question everybody's
asking right
he just implicated himself in a felony
as well by the way thanks for that yeah
gerard you look like you want to say
something about this oh
man i should let everybody else go first
because i feel pretty strongly about
this one
tell us tell us what you do look this is
this is endemic of a a wider societal
issue
the the elites have are so far gone
they're so far gone from the reality of
everyday life
you know this is these are people that
you know when they were shutting down
the coal mines they were like well just
learn how to code
why don't these guys just learn how to
code man they're 45 years old 50 years
old they've been working in a mine for
20 years and you're like yeah just
just go to devry and learn how to code
get a job in i.t they work
remotely these are people with
high-paying six-figure jobs that all
they need
is high-speed internet and they can work
from aspen and they're like well
who cares if i don't have to go to an
office they don't think about
the office building supports the dry
cleaner down the block supports the
pizzeria down the block
the barber down the block there's an
entire ecosystem
that is around supporting them the
high-wage earner
but they've been they've spent their
whole life going to private schools
going to you know these high-end ivy
league universities and then they go to
these google campuses
they've never been around quote-unquote
normal people you know this is where you
get this gail gadot
you know and all these hollywood elites
thinking they're going to cheer us up
during the quarantine like
you know singing that song imagine like
we're in this together guys
and it's malibu in her backyard with a
20 000 square foot house and i'm sitting
in here
in a one bedroom in jersey city above an
indian restaurant going out of my mind
like
we are in this together we are not in
this this is an indian restaurant get me
out of this
i'm smelling curry 24 7. get me gail
gadot i swear
if you sing one more time i am gonna
say it thinks that i got a tillis gym in
jersey brother bro
they shut down the gyms and the churches
during a pandemic so we can't be healthy
spiritually emotionally or physically
but they kept the liquor stores and
burger king open man
like come on bro this is what i'm
talking about this is a let them eat
cake moment
this is why i love gerard i love
data so i brought billy bean to one of
our events i don't know what it was two
years ago or two years ago i said two
years ago i brought vision
to mgm yeah but we only did it at the md
meeting was only the brokers mean it
wasn't for everybody right and i'm
interviewing uh billy bean he says you
know when you're winning
you love data when you're losing you
hate looking at the numbers
because it's not the numbers fault it's
it's something else it's you know it's
this it's that it's this right it's
never the you know it's
no there's a whole story behind it right
okay
you can get up there and talk about
everything you want about the right
decisions we made etc etc
then comes data and then you have to say
why did florida's
shutdown format work why did
texas work why did why why didn't
california work
why didn't new york work i mean within a
span of a week we were both in new york
and in california
right new york everywhere we're going
we talked to the cab driver cab driver
was like no we felt the shutdown half a
million people have left this place
california we go there
mario and i are at uh i don't know where
we went we want to get this uh uh
food by the water this guy runs up stop
stop stop stop stop put the mask on
completely different environment that
they got but
phil the the gym the fitness world
you're in that space
how big of a hit that they take you know
like now it's
after pandemic how big of a hit have
some people taking did some people fully
get out of the business
there's a lot of gems that suffered no
question about it and
um unfortunately those personal trainers
they suffer
tremendously because they can't even the
ones that do like online workout
programs yeah
they're working from home but they also
are working internationally
so imagine not just the people who they
can help domestically in the united
states but overseas they still don't
have gyms
so a lot of the personal trainers are
like well what do i do how do i really
pivot
and even those influencers that are like
you know you got bodybuilding and
influencers
kind of mixed together what are they
going to do just home workouts all the
time eventually that became boring
and it became very i would say
disingenuous to say that
i got my physique based on this so a lot
of people
had to really just take a hiatus and a
lot of athletes
were furloughed like crazy a lot were
let go
contracts from the supplement companies
i mean supplement companies
i mean they all lost their ass
tremendously so
they're just now starting to i say uh
turn the corner a little bit but i think
uh
those people that are turning it are
probably watching valuetainment
and learning how to be a better
businessman you know to understand that
this may happen again so how do we
you know solve that problem yeah
but the unfortunate problem part is that
a lot of them still haven't figured out
like a specific
training module or whatever to enhance
like their
abilities and i know we were talking
about stuff like that last night is that
you have an online course if somebody
wants to learn how you all your secret
stuff that you've done over there is
that like an online course survive yours
or no
not yet in the process oh bro people
would pay
premium for that to get their hands on
how you train like you don't have a
video that shows how you trained with a
camera showing exactly your routine i've
had uh workout videos
you know dvds all that stuff you know
i've done collaborations with different
companies
but uh no wow
something's coming though well if
something like that i hope so because i
know a lot of us would want to jump are
you kidding me
you got a seventh semester who is still
who is still in shape like you can
compete this year if you wanted 100
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]